well good afternoon everyone my name is
Peter Sullivan the president of Yale
University and welcome to this semesters
president's women of Yale lecture
although we're not actually going to
have a lecture we're gonna have a
conversation but last fall we began this
series as a way to showcase the
accomplishments of women who graduated
from Yale and we've had a particular
focus on women of color our guests
include our distinguished speaker today
and need a hill and they represent the
very best of this university they
reflect on the remarkable success of
women who have studied it yell in the
College since co-education and in the
professional and graduate schools for
much much longer it was in fact the idea
of my wife Marta marette herself a woman
of yell in 1984 graduate of the School
of Public Health who first proposed the
idea that we should have a speaker
series that would bring some of Yale's
most inspiring women back to campus I
hope some of you were with us for
earlier talks our first speaker in the
series was Maya Lin the pioneering
architect and artist who graduated from
Yale College in 1981 she earned her
master's from the School of Architecture
in 1986 returned to yellow gear later
and received an honorary degree of Fine
Arts many of you of course know the
women's table the sculpture in front of
the library is Maya Lin and of course
everyone knows the Vietnam Veterans
Memorial earlier this year we welcomed
Vera wells a member of the class of 1971
the first Yale college she was in the
first Yale College graduating class to
include women and she told us a very
compelling story about the first tenured
woman of color on our faculty we're
approaching the 50th anniversary of
co-education in Yale College and each of
these events in the president's women of
Yale extra series as a way to honor
the remarkable contribution of our
alumni in 2019 we will get to that
anniversary here and we will host a
major celebration of co-education at
Yale it's a milestone that I'm very
excited about and I know you are as well
but that's the 50th anniversary of
co-education in Yale College it's also
important to recognize that women have
studied at Yale far longer than that it
goes back nearly 150 years and in fact
in that very same year 2019 we will
celebrate 150 years of women studying in
the graduate and professional schools
since 1869 the journey for women to gain
access to the highest rungs of higher
education has not been easy and women of
color have faced even greater barriers
in 1939 Jane Bolin became the first
african-american woman to graduate from
the Yale Law School at age 31 the mayor
of New York appointed her to a judgeship
in the city's Domestic Relations Court
making her the first female
african-american judge in the United
States in his announcement mayor
LaGuardia praised Bowen for translating
her knowledge and understanding into
useful public service much could be said
of our guest much the same could be said
of our guest today Anita Hill received
her JD from the Yale Law School in 1980
following graduation she worked in
private practice and then at the US
Education Department and Equal
Employment Opportunity Commission in
1989 she became the first
african-american to be tenured at the
University of Oklahoma College of Law in
nineteen she then became a professor at
Brandeis rising to university professor
of law public policy and women's studies
and teaching courses on gender race
social policy and legal history as
counsel to the law firm Cohen and
Millstein chair Cohen Milstein she
advises on class action worth
place discrimination cases her scholarly
accomplishments include editing the
volume race gender and power in America
the legacy of the hill Thomas hearings
and authoring an autobiography speaking
truth to power most recent writings
include the book reimagining equality
stories of gender race and finding home
which I've been reading this week which
among a series of interrelated topics
from the play Raisin in the Sun - which
is kind of an ongoing metaphor or
analogy throughout the book - what
happened in the city of Baltimore -
stories of her own family and and others
like them the book really focuses on on
the American dream the dream of a home
and of home ownership in particular and
how it's been challenged and compromised
most recently in the fall of 2008 and in
2009 by the Great Recession the credit
crisis subprime mortgage crisis and how
all of these issues of home and and
homeownership interrelate - concerns of
race gender and class in 2015 in Nita
Hal was a wreckin it was recognized as a
university professor by the Brandeis
University Board of Trustees this year
she is on leave visiting MIT
experiencing a different home
environment I guess I would say as you
know she's a dedicated advocate for the
rights of women her testimony before the
US Senate during the Clarence Thomas
Supreme Court confirmation hearings made
her a national symbol of the challenges
women particularly women of color face
in this country since then she has
continued to work to end sexual
harassment and workplace discrimination
her public Avice advocacy and
scholarship helped us to understand how
gender and race interact to form potent
barriers to success for girls and women
and today I am just honored and proud to
welcome to Yale back to Yale I need a
Hill one of the truly outstanding
women of Yale University so our format
today and we in this lecture series we
keep trying different formats to see
what works best I'm going to ask
professor Hillson questions and she will
speak to them and then we have questions
from all of you that should be on three
by five cards and once they make their
way up here sorted out by not by how
controversial or non controversy they
are but rather by how legible they are I
will then ask some questions that you
all submitted so let me start with a
little bit of an autobiographical
question about your time here at Yale
obviously the Yale School of Law the
Yale Law School is a unique and
interesting environment in and of itself
and I'd be very interested and I know
everyone here would be very interested
in hearing whether the experience here
was formative for you in some way and
just how how things have evolved since
those days at the Yale Law School I will
say that when I applied to law school I
applied to several law schools as most
people do and I thought I wanted to go
to Harvard and then I visited Harvard
and I decided I really wanted to go to
Yale and one of the reasons that I
wanted to go to Yale was a guy named
Thomas I got I think I may have a couple
of law school classmates here at
Maryland is one of them I I came to Yale
Law School in 1977 and it really was to
me like walking into
alien space not only because I had never
really experienced life out of Oklahoma
and at that part of the world but the
way of learning and the concepts were
really quite alien to me and I had to
figure out exactly how I was going to
embrace it it was we you know you had
mentioned that the professional schools
had had women for a while and my law
school class there were 33 or cocido
about 30% of the class were women so and
that was significant it didn't feel so
strange as some of the early years I
think of having women in the college but
it was still that wasn't the alien part
I did feel that there were a critical
number of women there were fewer
percentage-wise
of people of color as a matter of fact
in my class I think there were 12
African Americans and 11 of them were
women and so in Maryland is one of those
what a graduate in 1980 with me and so I
how to figure out how does someone from
Oklahoma there may have been to build
people in the entire building from
Oklahoma who is african-american who is
female come into this space that's been
traditionally space for wealthy white
males and by the way I was from a farm
in Oklahoma so I was it was a quite
unique experience for me and what I
found was that if I was ever going to
grasp these alien concepts was it that I
would have to in fact embrace and find
some things that were familiar and to
ground myself in the
things that I knew and felt comfortable
with in order to be able to expand and
to grow and I was able to do that by
making some really incredible
friendships with a lot of people but in
particular the african-american students
to be able to have an organization like
balsa black Law Students Association as
a support system and a sort of a
friendship system but also a
professional organization to be able to
we had to kind of connect with other
women in the class and at that point
once I did that I was able to really
embrace the experience but I had to
start with the things that were familiar
to in order to be able to expand out and
the more support systems that I could
have had we didn't have a lot then but
those that were there were really quite
effective and so it was then possible
for me to I look back at some of the
things that I did I was and a clinic for
children and representing children with
Steve and Judith Resnik is here and so
and indenting Curtis as well oh but if I
was able to be a class officer I was
able to do MOOC or you know I was able
to do all of the things that you can do
in law school it makes the experience
better but only because I had that base
that I could always go back to and that
would make me feel supported and
welcomed and I was really I think that
that that helped me here and it allowed
me to be comfortable and also successful
and to graduate I might have otherwise
been back in Oklahoma quite early so to
ask a question I think must be on
everyone's mind your testimony before
Congress 25 years ago more than 25 years
ago now was an incredibly brave act that
changed that that that in many ways
changed the the national conversation
about sexual harassment sexual
misconduct but my guess is you probably
view some things as having changed and
some things not as having changed since
that time and I'd be really interested
in your take on women in the workplace
now versus then and you know have we
made progress and in what ways now at
the 26 year slice is an interesting era
I think from 1991 to look at but I think
we I want to kind of give a shout out to
some of my fellow Yale graduates on the
issue of sexual harassment in 1975 a
graduate eleanor holmes norton that was
the first woman she graduated in 1964 i
believe was one it was the first person
ever to hold public hearings on the
issue of sexual harassment about the
same time Catherine MacKinnon started
laying the legal groundwork for sexual
harassment to actually come to the
courts and to be able to raise claims of
what were the strategies and how was it
going to work and what was the argument
for being covered by Title 7 I testified
in 1991 and in 2014 Catherine layman who
is a 1996 graduate I believe was the
person who rode a second set of
guidelines for colleges and universities
on title 9 to deal with the issues of
sexual harassment and sexual assault on
campuses so I am one of the things that
I have to say it I don't know that much
has been made of this but they're women
and Yale Law School have actually had I
believe a real impact
and made the idea of sexual harassment
something really tangible and real oh
and I think it's important for us to
look at where we've come not starting in
1991 but really starting in 1975 when
Eleanor Holmes Norton really had the
temerity to do these hearings about a
subject and few people were even paying
any attention to and Catherine MacKinnon
was was developing a legal strategy for
how to move forward in the courts on
these claims my testimony really was and
bringing some of these issues and
awareness to public consciousness and
making it part of the public discussion
and then Catherine layman who has really
sort of made real that public discussion
in guidelines and for colleges and
universities to actually start to do
something about these issues I also have
to point out that three of those women
are women of color so we think that it's
important for us to say well where were
we then and where are we now but I think
we also have to look at different kinds
of milestones where we were in 1991
after my testimony I cannot tell you how
many people I heard from who said who
didn't even know that sexual harassment
was against the law it was just
something that happened to them they
didn't know that there was something
that that's some way to call it out and
certainly didn't know that there was a
way to challenge it and I think you know
that that's the real shame of the legal
profession because we have this problem
that had been well documented by the
surveys that was happening to women
every day and in the workplaces and
throughout you know every sector and
that they didn't know that they had
rights to
make it stop that they had to ride to be
at a workplace that was free of
harassment and so I started wondering
why that was and and that's what I went
left law teaching and went into policy
school but to get from that point in
1991 to where we are now where we have
this part of this huge public
conversation I think it's quite
significant so how did we get there one
in 1991 people started filing complaints
in record numbers they stepped up
because they you know even the pundits
said oh nobody's gonna come forward now
because they've seen how badly you
retreated and nobody wants to be treated
in that way I mean and the assumption
behind them was that everybody should
expect to be treated badly when they
raise the sexual harassment claim and
that's not far from the truth
because unfortunately there's still a
great deal of retaliation for women who
filed against women who filed sexual
harassment complaint in fact about 60%
of more will get be retaliated against
but so the record numbers of people
coming filing EEOC complaints after 1991
there was actually a change in law that
allowed for the first time women to
recover fully
for injured their injury when they were
sexually harassed they had there were
there was one Supreme Court case it was
a 1986 case one major case in the
Supreme Court on sexual harassment by
1991 now we have a fuller body of law
some of it problematic I think and
unhelpful to and and really unrealistic
in terms of some of the constraints that
are put on people filing complaints and
holding employers liable but we've got a
stronger grounding in the law we started
to raise awareness one of the things
that happen to have to know
you know anyone that people started
sharing their stories with their family
members that had not been done before
and I think that's absolutely something
that's significant and we kind of don't
think is that important but when you're
talking about changing public awareness
and public consciousness one of the best
things that can happen is that people
tell their stories to people who care
about them and who they care about so
those things have all happened but as we
know from the headlines lately it's not
over and so now we have a new wave of a
new generation of women but I have to
tell you that I think that at every
decade whether it was in the 70s when
those pioneer women were filing sexual
harassment complaints and they were just
being some of them were being told that
these were personal matters and not
legal matters some of the cases were
rejected finally you had a Supreme Court
decision validating their their
positions from the 70s to the 90s when
those women came forward after the
hearings despite what people told them
that they wouldn't be heard to the years
after and raising a generation of young
women to understand that sexual
harassment was illegal and that it was
wrong I think all of those brought us to
where we are today so that you now have
people coming forward telling their
stories whether it is to the press or to
the to on social media and I think that
much of that attention that is going on
now is because the press has gotten
better
the press has gotten better we've you
know when in 1991 over and over again
and even in the years since then people
have said well why don't women come
forward I mean even though there
are living examples of why they don't
come forward because people keep asking
you why you don't come forward even
though you tell them over and over again
but when we see why women don't come
forward because they get bruised and
battered and and we injured in coming
forward and we're now moving it seems at
least in the public conversation beyond
that question and we're looking at not
only the behavior which is egregious and
horrific in some of the cases that we've
heard about whether it's Roger Ailes or
Harvey Weinstein or James Toback I mean
all of these behaviors we're focusing on
that but I think we're also focusing on
something that is much more important
and that is the structures and the
people and the systems that enable it
and that is a breakthrough to have the
public discussion talking about well how
do people get away with it not how do
women why don't women come forward but
how do you get away with it in Harvey
Weinstein's situation for three decades
and what we are starting to see is that
there are particular structures and I
use Harvey once in all of us as a case
study you know some of the things he
said he didn't do some of the things he
says he admits to doing but you know I'm
clear and different places outside of
Hollywood you will find Harvey
Weinstein's and they may not make movies
and they may not be as wealthy but they
behave in some of the same ways well
you've got contractors you've got a
board of directors that ignores the
flags
you've got what I call gag orders when
settlements are reached you have these
non-disclosure clauses and the contracts
of people who are employees
who cannot talk about what they see in
the workplace and you have arbitration
clauses it's some circumstances where
people cannot adjudicate their claims so
that no one knows that these claims even
exist you also have people who are sort
of passed along even if maybe someone
you know maguet punished and who moved
out of a system they get moved into
another system and nobody knows that
they have been engaging in sexual
harassment and that happens a lot in the
Academy Wow and so you've got that sort
of first layer of protections that kind
of set up a shield around the harasser
that allows them to continue and we're
starting to understand that but one of
the things that Harvey Weinstein
situation also points out is that
there's sort of a secondary level of
protections that come when people give
you Awards in acknowledgments and
recognitions because you're a powerful
person and they want to be associated
with that power or for whatever reason
they're looking at the position and
those are used to kind of fend off any
accusations and those are typically
going to be the men they're not going to
be the women who are the accusers who
have these kinds of accolades and sort
of give them the sort of stamp of
approval you know I can you know Harvey
Weinstein is one example Roger Ailes was
seen as a genius Bill Cosby was seen as
American father and you know not long
ago Yale Law School gave Clarence Thomas
their highest honor so and and before
then they had given it to Bill Clinton
so these so we have to ask all of us
have to ask ourselves are we enablers
are we participating in it when we
ignore these stories
that we've heard about people and then
give them big awards and in a sense give
them a little bit of cover and maybe in
some cases a lot of cover for bad
behavior so we're just now I think
starting to get to all of those things
but that's where we are we have with
so you just traced the the kind of
individual standing alone to the social
larger social context that enables it it
makes me want to follow up with a little
bit of a personal question when I look
at the situation today the one you know
that is in the news today this week
versus you more than 25 years ago you
didn't have the context of hashtag me to
write people coming forward and
supporting each other and and
essentially a movement developing around
people coming public because stating in
public this also happened to me at least
not even not at all to the extent that
we're now seeing you know in the in the
Weinstein case and so I guess my
question is that this must have taken an
incredible act of courage to do it alone
yes you know you you mentioned the the
great legal minds who worked on these
issues and created a way forward but you
had to decide yourself that I was gonna
come forward and talk about this in in
Congress in front of people are gonna be
quite hostile to it in front of a media
that didn't really understand the issue
and how did you muster the courage to do
it I had any idea exactly what it was
going to be like I'm looking at Judy
right now because I think I was able to
come forward in a lot of ways I had
really I knew I would have the support
of my family but I also had the support
of my colleagues in law teaching and
Judas was one of those it was Emma :
Jordan there was Charles Ogletree all of
these people who sort of said look we've
we're going to help you get through this
when I had nobody
really
who was sort of thinking about I was
just sort of thrust in and I had less
than a week to prepare and so this group
of people who had been colleagues
actually stepped up I did have the
benefit of law teaching although this
was not my area of teaching but I do
think that was helpful I had a wonderful
family I had great colleagues and
supporters in my profession and I had
put supporters at the law school that I
was in and beyond that I just thought
you know I was a law teacher telling
people telling students every year you
know this is a system that you want to
value and believe in you wanted to have
integrity and for me the integrity of
the court was at stake and if in the
profession you know is only as sound as
its highest representative and so that's
what I was thinking of commitment that I
made myself I also you know I grew up I
was born in 1956 after just after the
Board of Ed Brown versus Board of
Education when schools were starting to
open up and opportunities were opening
up and I know how significant the law is
and how much it can mean in the lives of
people and when you're on the court that
and even one member can change the
trajectory of the law and a decision and
you know and there are five four
decisions now all the time so I I think
we you know it was all of those things
maybe I wasn't consciously thinking oh
this is a really brave thing to do but I
was thinking it was the right thing to
do and so that's how I managed to do it
knowing that it was the right thing to
do that what I had to say went to the
character and fitness of Clarence Thomas
to be on the court
and that it was not just about Clarence
Thomas but it was about the court and
the decisions that were gonna be coming
out of the court now for 26 years so it
was I think back now and I asked myself
would I do it again and I and my answer
is yes I would do it again but I don't
think I had really any idea what I was
getting into the first time but I would
do it again and I would do it again
because it was the right thing to do and
it was also not just the right thing to
do but what I didn't clearly understand
was that our voices were not being heard
women's voices and experiences were not
being valued in that process just showed
me that we weren't being in valued in
our processes our real experience our
lived experiences weren't being listened
to that we had senators who said oh well
I've never I have no idea about this
sexual harassment stuff what is it this
what does it mean I mean they went from
oh it doesn't exist to the person who
does it would have to be a monster I
mean they were just sort of all over the
place
in terms of their lack of understanding
and then you think well they don't
understand this about our experiences do
they really represent us and I think
that's why the hearings had such a
political impact none of that was what I
intended but but I've come to understand
that why it was important for me to be
there beyond the fact that I just
believed that the court was important
and that my testimony went directly to
character and I like to say unfitness to
be on the Supreme Court your comments
right now I was gonna ask you by the way
if you had any regrets you there there
is no trace of regret
your ads or your voice it's interesting
to hear the the certainty with which you
said that I was going to ask you when
you were just making a comment about the
inability in this case of members of
Congress to understand the experience
that people have every day unfortunately
and that puts me in the mind of another
brave Yale Law student someone who was a
doctoral student at the Yale Law School
a number of years before you were
student at the law school and that's
Pauli Murray you probably know that we
named a college for Pauli Murray not too
far from here a couple blocks from here
just earlier this academic year in fact
about three weeks ago we dedicated Pauli
Murray college and Pauli Murray coined
the phrase Jane crow to describe a kind
of double discrimination that women of
color particularly black women she was
really speaking more broadly with women
of color experience in this in our
country and that issue may is it is of
current interest to our students in
recent years and in scholarly writings
as well and I'm wondering from your view
you know how far have we come with
respect to double discriminations of
this kind and or do they reckon recommen
represent a kind of unique difficulty
that needs to be addressed in its own
right and not necessarily as part of
something else well I do believe that
back to the earrings just quickly I did
experience a sort of double
discrimination where Clarence Thomas was
allowed to represent the race and I was
allowed to represent gender and so the
question was whether or not he
deserved really to be able to represent
the race
given the fact that I too am
african-american but they the public
really didn't have a narrative for the
experiences of african-american limited
especially that an error they had they
had the the lynching narrative that was
is so appalling and so even now present
in our our society that's there's ideas
around the elimination of people through
just public executions but they didn't
have or hadn't been taught the history
of the sexual violence against African
American women or they didn't want to
understand that so that they could say
that that is part of the racial
narrative and and in some ways that is
you know how we you know that's part of
what Paula Murray was talking about that
not in the specifics of gendered
violence but there is a really good
essay I think on on the difference that
my race made that's written by Leon
Higginbotham that I recommend to any of
you who know Leon Higginbotham also
knows he's a Yale graduate I do know
people who aren't you know law school
graduates but he's a he's a particularly
special one who wrote a really sort of
deconstructing the whole sundae scene
what would happen if you know I had been
white and Clarence Thomas were who he is
and I use an example this is not his but
my example is that what would the Strom
Thurmond have done would he have
embraced him and I think that is part of
what it's so now that's 1991 Pauli
Murray was talking about what we now
call intersection
back in the 1960s I mean that's to me is
is something that we don't we don't give
Paula Murray enough credit for one big
influential in the race of mud and in
the women's movement singular in each
one of those places but also really
theorizing them enough to understand
where some people were falling out of
both of those movements and and for her
case it was women of color I mean she
she one person who does give Pauli
Murray credits you know it's Ruth Bader
Ginsburg in terms of her work that she
did for the ACLU but mostly she's not
recognized either as a theorist or as an
organizer and she was both she was just
incredibly inquisitive and questioning
the way things are to the to the ascent
achievement question her own gender
identity I mean there was it was the
time she was had the kind of mind that
just sort of pushed everything I I know
second hand because she was a teacher of
a colleague of mine at Brandeis and that
was her nature that was who she was to
always be pushing and pressing and
trying to get the answers when she
talked about intersectionality or what
it's become intersectionality and she
called it Jane crow she did it in a
speech that was given to the National
Conference of Negro Women in 1963 and
she did it in response to the fact that
african-american women's voices were
excluded from the march on Washington
that they had been involved in a lot of
the work of the civil rights movement
they've been doing the ground work but
they were not given speaking roles at
that
and and I guess to add injury insult to
injury the organizers the male
organizers on the day or so after the
March went to the press collaging
tempore a breakfast and it was all no
women were allowed so you know she saw
this inconsistencies and the way the a
philip Randolph was actually
interpreting equality and she sort of
laid out the different ways that people
had thought that oh if we give
african-american men jobs that women
will benefit and that will be enough and
she was saying well you know there are
african-american women who need who are
qualified and could benefit from the job
and the entire race would benefit and I
think we've come to that yeah we've
understood then that now but she also
saw problems with the women's rights
movement that african-american women
were not included in that she was
talking about the gender race pay
disparities in 1963 and so all of these
things for me really words just so far
ahead of their time are we truly
understanding now what it means what
intersectionality means it's gotten
disparaged by a lot of theorists legal
theorists and I happen to have spent
some time with kimberlé crenshaw
who is now really devoting most of her
work intersectionality so she's starting
to look at how it plays out in
structures and systems against women of
color and especially when it comes to
gendered violence but I mean just give
you a couple of examples one is in the
Academy and one of the things that we
are finding is that Asian American women
in the photo in the last one
so years have been denied tenure and at
a much higher rate than other candidates
oh and they sort of Saints have been a
wave of these denials of tenure that
don't seem to be explained by anything
other than kind of this concept of you
know they're of a race and gender
combining moving or disadvantaging but
the other piece of it is if you think
about hiring a you if you're an
african-american woman or an Asian woman
and you're filing a discrimination suit
the employee your defend that
discrimination sued by saying well you
know I'm not discriminating against
women because I've hired many women or
they can they can defend against that I
said well you know I've hired a number
of Asian men and there is no clear path
to claim that you you are discriminating
on the basis of both race and gender in
those cases there are arguments that
have been made but it hasn't been
declared as sort of covered covered
under the existing legal structures and
so those are the kinds of things that
we're still experiencing I call these
big gaps in the law in terms of what
what how do we deal with intersectional
issues and so we're we're not we're not
there yet there has been no big
pronouncement about how to deal with
that case where well a hired Asian men
so they can't be discriminating against
Asians there's but there's also an
interesting study that's out I find it
interesting anyway because I made MIT
now but but it's a a study of women of
color
honors and what they found was that and
there was a study about harassment oh
they found that women of color
astronomers were more likely to be
sexually harassed than white women
astronomers but they also found that
they were more likely to be racially
harassed
than male astronomers who are men of
color so the question is how do you
treat that when you how do you how do we
think about that and and why is that
happening
is it it not doesn't seem to be
completely gender nor does it seem to be
completely race it's both and how does
the law recognize that in a system that
really looks like categories
individually so we're not there in terms
of the law and I don't think we're there
in terms of culturally understanding
what Jane crow or it's modern-day
iterations are let's go with the MIT
comment that you just made and not
talking about MIT per se but talk about
the tech industry you just wrote a
recently an op-ed piece for the New York
Times where you talked about a pay gap
and a promotion gap that women face in
the tech industry and I'm wondering if
you would share some of your thoughts
about the technology sector and what's
happening we do hear a little bit about
the interest in Silicon Valley and
addressing the challenge although it's
not clear that progress is being made in
it with any rapidity well it seems to me
that the problem now that we look at all
these big scandals whether it's uber or
Tesla or you know the problems with
venture capitalists in
Silicon Valley that what we see is this
sort of new economy replicating some of
the traditions of the old there are
three things that I think are
problematic not just a pay gap but the
pay gap the lack of leadership the
gender diversity and racial diversity
and leadership and I always tell my
policy students if you ever you discover
a gendered gender discrimination keep
looking because you're gonna find raise
two or you're gonna find sexual identity
discrimination where you're gonna find
disability and you're gonna find some
other discrimination but so there's the
pay gap there's a lack of leadership in
the diversity and then this this toxic
toxic harassment culture that exists so
all of those things come together and
they're interrelated and it's like you
cannot deal with one without dealing
with all of them and so we really don't
quite know what where to start we look
at some of the pay gap the issues you've
got women under the age of 25 who are
making 29 percent less than their
counterparts women who go in and
negotiate a salary a 63 percent more
likely to get less money than the men
negotiating a salary the problem with
that is that what it says is that this
pay gap that we thought we were closing
is not closing and this emerging economy
and and it's also problematic and
troubling because these economies are
being run by men typically who grew up
in an age where women were 40 percent of
the workplace most of them had working
or many of them had working well there
so how is it is the discrimination so
embedded in who they are or in the world
that they cannot
they're way out of it is this is this
the way the future is going to look and
I think that's to me why I look at the I
look at at Silicon Valley in the tech
industry industries and I'm so troubled
by it it's because we hoped that things
would change not because they're liberal
and politically liberal and you know but
because it's new and it's a new
generation and we've been told that this
generation doesn't see differences
racial and gender it's not there they
are much more open-minded but they're
not behaving in the way so I think that
this is a moment where we really ought
to be looking at scrutiny with at these
at Silicon Valley and what's going on
out there and what is it the culture
that is creating this or contributing to
it but what I didn't say in that very
Times piece is something that I think we
also have to understand that's almost
Silicon Valley it's a live laboratory of
a community and so when we think of
Silicon Valley we tend to think of
Silicon Valley as a you know really
highly educated computer scientists or
maybe MBA graduates many of them ba
graduates from Harvard we're going out
there and running these businesses but I
think we all are as we're concerned
about the salaries and pay of the people
who work in Google we need to be also
concerned about the salaries and pay of
the other people in our community like
the people who take care of the children
are the people who work in Google and
the people who are the teachers in their
community that while the tech industry
is booming their salaries aren't booming
and they can't even live in the
communities where all of this is going
on so I think we need to start looking
at gender equality and equity not just
from a thin slice of the economy but as
a sort of a lateral but also
looking throughout the system that is
the tech industry and looking at how
women throughout that system are faring
and we haven't quite gotten that figured
out to it I think that again is going to
be a retelling of the direction that
this country is going in and especially
when we sort of put the tech industry
out there as an example of success of
economic success but we need to be
asking our question the question
economic success for whom and even if we
get equality for the women who are
working in the c-suite is that going to
then filter into the rest of the
community and those are the questions
that I think are the sort of the bigger
questions that we need to have and use
tech as an example yeah before we turn
to questions from the audience let me
ask one follow-up to that do you
expressed some disappointment about the
tech industry but a lot of
disappointment about the tech industry
but in particular the fact that it's
young and that one would have expected
that because it's a young industry that
where people claim not to see difference
or what have you at least not in a
prejudiced way that the the results
would be more positive so let me turn
that a little bit on it on it said you
spent a lot of time talking to students
at Brandeis now at MIT in front of
audiences made up in part of students at
universities like Yale and around the
country is there something that you are
hearing in the generation of young
people today that gives you more
optimism than say the tech industry has
provided well putting those two things
together I think it I am optimistic
because I hear what I hear from students
is activism
I mean we've got activism we said we
have many of the the movement in
colleges and universities get sexual
harassment and sexual assault is because
of student activism young women decided
that they were going to move on this
issue that it was it was important for
them even though some of them had left
the schools that they were in and and I
don't think I've seen that kind of
activism whether it's gender activism or
activism toward racial inclusion which
I've seen over throughout the country I
don't think that's that's by chance I
think we're in that moment now where we
can really be happy and satisfied at
least from my point of view that we're
making these movements and progressive
directions now I also hear them being
very inclusive that they want to bring
in other people in this conversation
they want other leaders they don't want
leaders that just look all the same they
don't want ideas that just come from the
same experiences or the same place they
don't want to just cover one issue they
want to cover a range of issues in terms
of the progress now the concern I have
with regard to the tech industry is will
bat die once they get beyond the college
situation and university situation will
they sort of fall back on old prejudices
and all kinds of ways of thinking the
way it seems to have happened in with
these young leaders and tack on the
other thing though that I have to say is
that we are now experiencing on those
campuses
you know this pushback and some of the
pushback of course is coming from
outside those people who
think that college campuses are all you
know about liberals and I mean I think
it was George Will that says it was you
know sexual assault wasn't real that it
was just about academic progressivism
claiming victimhood or some rarefied
state they that you got pushback from
outside but you also have pushback from
inside that universities are really
traditional places I think just in case
you didn't know this then these young
people are challenging some traditions
that I frankly have outlived their
usefulness in my mind and that's really
hard and so when you've got those
external forces and you have internal
forces when you've got people who say oh
well we've gone far enough from the
outside or we even get impact on too far
and then you have people internally who
are really resistant to even looking at
their traditions to see if they are
still valuable it's difficult to make
change what I hope is that for young
people that it will always be this
experience of trying to make change in
universities and then throughout the
world will be a learning experience but
it won't I'm hopeful it and will kill
their spirit and sort of send them out
into the world to just accept accept the
status quo thank you for that somebody I
think has a deck of cards for me and
that would be joy okay thank you so why
don't we turn to a few of your questions
we have 10-15 minutes and we can take a
few questions
we'll try to get to as many as we can
so the first few questions are actually
people seeking your advice and let me
take them I guess I'll do them one at a
time but will will will take them let me
take a look here from actually you know
what I'm gonna read all three and then
you can jump in on on any anywhere you
want so what advice would you give for
young women especially young women of
color aspiring to work in male-dominated
spaces like the legal field second one
is as a woman of color what do you hope
young girls of color will take away from
your story and how including Yale and
how you've lived your life and the last
one what advice do you have for women
who actually have experienced gender
prejudice of different kinds in the in
the workplace that was from a staff
member the first two were from students
so I general area I don't give blanket
advice because I you know I I know that
everyone's situation is its unique to
their experience in their settings so I
don't say oh you have to file a
complaint but what I do people tell
people is to understand what your
situation is in terms of moving toward a
complaint if that is what you're
interested in to it you've got to
understand the system you've got to
understand what the investigation
process is whether or not you're going
to be able or to respond to any kind of
answers whether you know who's gonna be
doing the evaluation who they're gonna
question everything and understand what
your own support systems are oh and
that's what that's kind of advice that I
give everybody I said you know just like
I started out saying you know what's
ball so it was a black women in my class
and was you know it was my friends who
kind of knew where Oklahoma was all of
those things were things that helped me
to get through it and whether or not
you're going into a male-dominated
question whether you're going to a file
a complaint you really have to go into
this with a understanding of how you're
going to be supportive because I haven't
ever come across any woman who is my age
or even reasonably younger who hasn't
needed that support I haven't run across
a person of color who has it needed that
support because of some of the sometimes
open hostilities and sometimes just
microaggressions that they experience
and you need somebody that you couldn't
be able to talk to about what that is
like so finding that support system
whatever it is and I'm very fortunate
because I had it I can say I have no
regrets now because that's what I have
and that's what I continue to have right
this is a question from a student in the
class of 2018 this person says this room
appears to have fewer younger students
than most the elements I thought it said
fewer younger people and I was going to
say present company notwithstanding but
fewer younger students than most the
elements do you think or what do you
think young people misunderstand about
the history of sexual misconduct and
sexual harassment I think people do you
know I'm not surprised that younger
people don't have any idea who I am I
really I I'm on a college campus trust
me
and and I think that we have a very
different idea of what history is what
recent history is the older we are than
younger people they win but I think I'm
probably not the person to ask what
young people why young people are not
present or what their understanding is I
think we but I would love to have that
conversation not just because they I
want them to come to see me but because
I think it is important for us to really
try to bridge the gaps to get their
their sense of you know to help really
them build on history and to know
because I think if they do they will
know that there are people who have been
fighting for this and that there are
examples of times when we've actually
won even when it didn't look like we
were winning there are times in Game one
because we have advanced these issues to
the place where it is today
and so where they are today so I think
that is important and and I don't know
how to start that conversation but I'm
I'm hopeful that we can at this point
when we got so much attention now to the
issue of sexual harassment then we can
use this as a moment where we can start
to bridge that I'm gonna do two more
because the next two were just really
good questions and they're all good
clear all good
all good so this is from a student in
the class of 2021 given both your
personal and your professional
experience with law do you think policy
or law can be written can ever be
written to serve specific ideals so to
serve the specific ideals that was
created for do you think all law
ultimately gets warped in a way to serve
someone's ideologue ideology or or
different values that then those that
created it well I guess my question
really is this can you ever be
idealistic about the law and about yeah
are you entirely cynical about the law
you know I think that one of the things
that we've got to understand is that and
it keeps you in this business and
believing that there are some principles
and I mean we talk as a country about
justice we talk about equality we talk
about equity and then you're absolutely
right that the law sometimes gets
co-opted for other purposes we've seen
that and very recently and we'll
probably continue to see it in the next
few years but that doesn't mean that we
have to throw away the law I think that
just means that this is a struggle and
it's an ongoing struggle that it doesn't
contend that you know those people who
said well I thought we should have been
done with sexual harassment by now well
we're talking about centuries upon
centuries of behavior that we thought we
could overturn in just you know 26 years
well that doesn't happen because for
every time there's a movement for where
there are people who are going to resist
it and so we just have to be vigilant
and to try to keep moving the law in the
right direction I won't give up on the
law and it's not just because I've
invested a career in it
but I won't give up on it but I'm also
not going to be satisfied with trying to
do it the same way
I do think we have to be imaginative I
think we have to be ever curious I think
Paula Murray is a great example of that
and I think that we have to think what
equality is for a new generation and all
of the different elements of it it's not
just about economics it's not just about
economic equality it's not just about
having the right job or being having
access to an education it's to me it's
about outcomes it's about how people
live their day-to-day lives and so I I
as long as we keep pushing as long as we
keep imagining as long as we keep
enlarging our sense of what justice is
law will always be able to play an
important role so our last question and
this comes from an alum who is here and
I'm going to paraphrase it just a little
bit and it has to do with the
accusations against Harvey Weinstein and
whether they represent some kind of
tipping point do we think that this case
in particular about workplace sexual
harassment is is somehow different and
will and will be the case the you know
and it's all of its attendant publicity
will be the case that really changes
things at least since Clarence Thomas
well I think that this I think I think
it's a mistake for us to think that
there's one case is it I think we've got
to look at the totality of the
circumstances you know we there's not um
you know a magic potion or one incident
or one example what I'm what I'm afraid
of is that we'll just sort of look and
start to so so narrow experiences of the
women in Hollywood and we won't start
looking at the women waiting tables and
the restaurant that you go to
that we won't look at the people who
were factory lines and we won't look and
women throughout employment then and
then we you know we sort of so
vulcanized this behavior that we won't
learn the larger lessons so I would sort
of said argue against even trying to
make Harvey Weinstein the case that will
turn everything around unless by that
you mean it's the case that will allow
us to see all other forms of gendered
violence and abuse and if we can look at
it that way if we can look at it as one
example that allows us to open our eyes
to what's going on historically and
today in so many places with so many
people then I think we can make some
advances with it
but even then I don't want people to
give up and say well you know I thought
Harvey Weinstein was gonna do it all and
it's not we still as I say have to
continue to be vigilant and we can still
have to look for new ways to really get
to people's lived experiences and and
and in order to actually put an end to
sexual harassment it's it's not it's not
going to be over be if you start to look
at how everyone sin it's a case the
solution is okay fire Harvey Weinstein
and then you leave a lot of people you
had a lot of different places stranded
because they don't meet the same kind of
behavior or they don't have the same
profile or for any number of reasons so
I think that we we've got we've got a
whole lot to learn but we shouldn't
think that this is the end can I thank
you for
thank you all
you